parce que nos villes se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces maillots yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable
au sommaire de ce numéro des économies
d'énergie peuvent être faites dans nos
habitations jusque dans sa construction
nous avons visité celle d'un couple de
trapil candidats au concours maisons
économes pour consommer local il ya les
hamacs les marchés mais aussi la vente
directe à la ferme de viltain c'est
notamment le lait et les produits
associés qui sont concernés un succès
auprès des consommateurs qui permet aux
gérants de développer leurs activités
dans le parc de fils à lui attrape une
école forme depuis 22 ans des étudiants
de problématiques environnementales
cette école c'est l'institut supérieur
de l'environnement nous nous y sommes
rendus là l'ex saint quentin l' agence
locale de l'énergie et du climat de
saint quentin en yvelines annoncé ce
mois ci mais vainqueur de la neuvième
édition du concours maisons économes
ce concours récompense les initiatives
et les changements de comportement
vis-à-vis de nos habitations
cette année un couple de trappistes y
participer ils ont choisi de faire
construire une maison passive un sujet
préparé avec elodie moines ossature bois
planchers en béton et bardage bois un
souci d'économie mais avant tout une
volonté d'autonomie énergétique
cette maison de 135 mètres carrés c'est
la réalisation d'un couple trappistes
les murs de leurs habitations font 40 cm
d'épaisseur et la maison est quasiment
hermétique leur habitation précédente
ancien énergivores a été totalement
rasée et reconstruite
il ya très peu de chômage en fait on
échauffé en quasiment en totalité par le
soleil qui a un petit apport énergétique
mais qui est extrêmement minime par
rapport à une maison classique
après il ya tout ce qui va de
ventilation double flux pour qui est
obligatoire en fait pour une maison
pour une maison passive qui est
complètement hermétique il ya de la
laine de laine de verre et c'est
polystyrène donc on est on est parti sur
les options notamment écologiques que le
coup dit rien il nous faisait dépasser
le budget de rentrée
le couple a décidé d'opter pour une
maison dite passive
un bâtiment qui en théorie n'a pas
besoin d'énergie pour se chauffer ou
très peu le 28 septembre dernier le jury
du concours maisons économes initiée sur
50 ha ennuyé par la lèque et vérifie
l'installation cette maison concourt
dans la catégorie construction
le concours mais inconnu c'est la 9e 10
ans cette année
il a pour objectif de valoriser les
projets particulièrement intéressant des
territoires donc soit technique dans la
construction la rénovation qui fait
appel à des techniques assez peu
répandue encore des matériaux pas trop
utiliser
jeudi 15 octobre les candidats sont
rassemblés pour connaître les résultats
sur les sept candidatures retenues par
le jury 3 concourait dans la catégorie
construction et c'est la maison
trappistes qui est désignée gagnante le
jury récompensant ainsi les performances
de la maison à la ferme de viltain
située à jouer en josas ont fait de la
vente directe pour tout ce qui concerne
les produits laitiers
un succès auprès des consommateurs qui
permet à la ferme de développer son
activité notamment avec la création
d'une nouvelle laiterie
nous avons rencontré l'un de ses
dirigeants benoît du prévôt jour vous
êtes l'agriculteur fromager de la ferme
alors aujourd'hui vous allez
augurer une nouvelle laiterie pourquoi
en fait
j'inaugure une là un agrandissement
notre laiterie parce qu'on a une
laiterie depuis très longtemps depuis
celle qui est actuel date de 1970 elle a
été rénovée déjà en 2003 et là on a fait
un agrandissement important puisqu'on a
ouvert un nouvel atelier de yahoo
c'était un besoin pour pouvoir suivre la
production on a la chance d'être porté
par l'engouement de
la clientèle pour les produits locaux
donc on a des collectivités qui nous en
demande des grosses quantités s'est pas
seulement la clientèle de détail donc
voilà équipe que produisez vous dans
cette lettre ils ont donc on produit du
lait frais du lait frais pasteurisé du
fromage blanc plusieurs sortes de
fromage blanc du fromage blanc en fait
celle du fromage blanc de campagne et
puis on produit aussi bien des yaourts
aux fruits que vous allez voir en
production et c'est en ce moment que on
est en train de les produire
vous avez agrandi ça va vous permettre
de fournir combien de produits
supplémentaires
est-ce que c'est déjà quantifiable non
parce que ça va à fur et à mesure qu'on
va avoir des clients mac
on va savoir on a une production qui
quand même importante puisque cette
machine permettent de produire 2000
yaourts à l'heure donc on a de quoi
faire
sachant qu'on est c'est un atelier qui
travaillent 39 heures par semaine dont 4
quoi faire en terme d'emplois ça vous a
demandé aussi d'embaucher d'autres
personnes alors ça a permis de créer
tout de suite un fromager
supplémentaires donc ils y sont rois
maintenant et puis un commercial
vous parliez tout à l'heure du local du
circuit court c'est une notion très
importante pour vous déjà c'est un lien
direct et puis physique comme je disais
tout à l'heure on se sent portée c'est
que les clients cherchent ce produit là
les parents d'élèves
on réclame dans les restaurants
scolaires
les représentants du personnel en
réclame dans les restaurations dans la
restauration d'entreprise donc eh bien
maintenant les restaurateurs viennent me
voir et souvent les premières ventes se
font avec une présentation de nos
produits directement dans la dans le
restaurant pendant une journée on est là
l'heure du déjeuner pour présenter nos
produits extra et on a toujours des très
bons retours et les clients sont
toujours très enthousiaste et son
sont contents de voir une ferme qui va
arriver tous les jours dans leur
quotidien delà du restaurant
d'entreprise
voilà enfin c'est donc ces sympathiques
et puis et puis nous pour nous c'est
aussi un débouché quand même important
de notre lait et une meilleure
valorisation de notre lait votre lait
justement il est d'ici produisez vos
produits votre propre les voilà donc on
a des vaches avec le lait de nos vaches
et bien on fabrique tous ses produits
directement c'est la traite du matin qui
va permettre la fabrication de nouilles
à ur de nos fromages etc vous avez
combien de vache ici hamilton à 300
vaches laitières
une production de lait actuellement de
dix mille litres de lait par jour on en
transe forme que 30%
donc on a de la marge et on peut en
vendre plein yaourt encore est pas mal
aussi de fromage blanc
vous parlez d'une marge le futur de la
femme de gilles tant au niveau de la
laiterie se ferait quoi bein c'est de
toutes écoulées mais enfin bon faut pas
rêver quand même parce que c'est une
chose importante c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on a embauché un commercial en plus
pour m'aider dans ce dans ses démarches
de trouver des nouveaux clients
nos ventes ne vont pas se faire du tout
sont pas tournés sur la grande
distribution c'est uniquement des
épiceries et puis les collectivités
toujours le plus proche du consommateur
pour être au plus proche du consommateur
et puis on peut les rencontrer plus
facilement je trouve merci vous ne
louperez votre accueil dans le parc
d'activités depuis salle ou attrape
existe depuis 1993 à l'institut
supérieur de l'environnement depuis sa
création l'école a formé plus de 700
étudiants métiers touchant à
l'environnement et au développement
durable
une formation mêlant cours théoriques et
me professionnels ou les étudiants
doivent innover portrait de l'école sur
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
lundi 22 septembre les étudiants de
l'institut supérieur de l'environnement
font leur rentrée
parmi eux se trouve peut-être de futurs
ingénieurs juristes des responsables le
développement durable ou encore à des
responsables d'hygiène qualité sécurité
environnement
on savait que l'on apprend
l'enseignement et
sur deux grandes thématiques
c'est des enseignements scientifiques et
l'ingénierie et des enseignements
juridique est en fait ces deux
fondements
ces deux fondamentaux font vraiment
l'essence même du projet pédagogique de
liesse et c'est ce qui permet aux
étudiants d'être bien arrivé après pour
intégrer la vie active chaque année une
trentaine d'étudiants sortent diplômés
en contact permanent avec le monde de
l'entreprise ils doivent réaliser des
projets tutorés plusieurs mois de
travail où il reçoit l'appui technique
de leurs professeurs
l'objectif de toute façon poursuit
décoller ce sujet c'est d'imposer ont
fait à nos étudiants de poursuivre comme
ça des projets ce qui à la fois leur
permet de développer des techniques de
management et en même temps pas d'avoir
aussi un pied dans le monde
professionnel puisque sur la plupart des
projets sur lesquels on faubel fait on a
de vrais professionnels avec lesquels
ils ont amené à travailler
parmi les projets cette machine portable
pour rendre de l'eau potable tout droit
sorti de l'imagination de ses cinq
étudiants de 4e année
le procédé ne peut encore être révélé le
brevet ayant pas été déposé la machine
est destiné à un usage individuel et
peut produire 80 litres d'eau par heure
donc a peut être aussi l'a adapté à
l'eau de rivière que halo de free c'est
une machine autonome donc en énergie
grâce à son panneau solaire est allé
portative donc telle une grosse mallette
donc là on a eu les stabilisateurs mais
ici ils peuvent être enlevés après aller
facilement déplaçable donc pèse 50 kilos
donc c'est très ça assez léger les
étudiants espèrent pouvoir l'installer
dans une école haïtienne en 2016 la
machine va être présenté à la bourse
totale campus dont les résultats seront
connus le 19 février prochain
six mois après la sortie de l'école 80%
des étudiants ont un emploi un défi
s'ajoute pour cette année être acteur de
la coop 21 la conférence sur le climat
qui débute à paris le 30 novembre
prochain
et avant nous quitter noter ces trois
rendez vous à ne pas manquer du 26 au 30
octobre c'est la semaine de
l'environnement attrape trois centres
sociaux et des bailleurs propose
ateliers et conférences pour
sensibiliser à l'environnement
toutes les informations sont sur le site
de la commune avec le jeu énergie 2020
vous voilà projetés cinq ans plus tard
neuf missions vous attendent pour rendre
le monde plus durable
alors si les enjeux de l'environnement
vous intéresse direction la médiathèque
du petit canal samedi 7 novembre et du
13 au 15 novembre
le 6 mai celle des noms courts composent
trois films documentaires notamment
thème l'environnement
bien sûr il sera question d'abeilles des
glaces de l'antarctique et du nucléaire
voilà équilibre c'est terminé je vous
donne rendez vous le mois prochain et
d'ici là pour sa faire un geste pour
l'environnement